maker check this out okay motto King
Grenn's or for the super graphics it's
uh it's only available in Japan
I got it in Akihabara it's 20 years old
it's still sealed got the shrink wrap on
it and everything is that crazy sweet I
know right well I got my lucky butter
knife right here let's crack this with a
cello hi the super graphics was a video
game system only released in Japan
during the 16-bit era as you might be
able to tell from its name it has a lot
of relation to the turbo graphics in
fact these super graphics is a turbo
graphics 16 with some extra RAM and
another video processing chip giving it
upgraded graphics power but that's about
it
consumers didn't really know whether it
was a new system or an old system with
better graphics and so nobody really
bought it and they only actually ever
made five games for the system so Baker
and I are going to sit down and play
them off okay
here's here's battle ace alright this is
the one Super graphics game that
everybody has because it's cheap as hell
this cost like eight dollars you go to
the technological mecca of Japan and
this is what you buy that's eight
dollars he would have been better spent
on the lunch in a maid cafe this is
probably the one console that makes
Atari Jaguar 3do fans feel like they
made a wise investment okay so you're
flying around in
sort of and I'll get hit once you die
and you die and he died and he died this
is the most Awkward drawn-out death
sequence since Sophia Coppola and
Godfather three so basically the super
graphics was any cease attempt to play
catch-up with the genesis in the Super
Nintendo which could both very easily do
game like this standing on their heads
and I missed out on the 16-bit era the
first time around now I feel like a
lucky sob hey it's dyma chimera also
known as ghosts and goblins or possibly
ghouls and ghosts I can never actually
remember which luckily I can never get
past the first stage so it doesn't
matter where you go you know there a
limited number of these of super
graphics games guessers no no I mean
these skeletons and dresses so yeah it's
possible you got 40 bucks that was a
wise investment
thank you forty dollars you could have
spent on a trip to the Bondi robot
Museum oh well the least this game is
actually fun I mean but how is this
different from the Super Nintendo
version oh the same you know one of the
things that super graphics can do as you
can see is have those multiple layers of
backgrounds that are scrolling
independently of each other an underwear
dude here what's his name that's Arthur
Arthur he gets hit and he's stripped to
his underwear yeah yeah wonder if
there's any fanfic about him never mind
never mind I didn't say that no links
please hey look its motto King grants
art that's the game that you ruthlessly
embracing li plundered its Maidenhead
not so long ago with your butter knife
thank you for conjuring that that image
in my head oh man this is some serious
magic this reminds me of the opening to
every public access show ever
wavy it's wavy whoa okay well we're in
the game
and apparently they've used up all the
super graphics on the title screen cuz
I'm not really seeing any super graphics
in here these graphics are not only not
super they're not even turbo this cell
was based on an anime series that I
think ran for about the same span of
time as the super graphics was on store
shelves so like a year and a half
okay so robot walking left swinging his
little sword I think I can understand
why this anime did not become the next
Dragonball on this episode of model king
ren sort robot walks the left and swings
his sword tune in next time man you're
this giant robot and you're swinging
this ridiculous little sword what what
did you pay for this one Oh God five
dollars and you don't feel bad that you
didn't spend that thirty five dollars on
35 capsule toys or something no I feel
bad that he didn't spend it on replays
of curry so you have to understand that
at the time probably a lot of people
actually bought this because the the
turbo graphics was pretty popular in
Japan that had been out since 1987 and
was a very clear improvement in graphics
over the 8-bit Nintendo and they weren't
in first place but NEC was a solid
number two I would describe this game as
a solid number two all Dynes before you
ask Baker this cost me $50 $50 who could
have spent on on a video game you might
actually play again someday
yeah well this game about 2020 ad this
game takes place twelve years from now
oh man we've that independently
scrolling background okay we get it
but I guess scrolling backgrounds really
were like serious matrix II Pixar
at the time so uh what's what's going on
here alien invasion dude maybe aliens
invaded because they're insanely jealous
of the earth scrolling background
technology all right let's man man super
graphics it's hard you know I am one hit
on like every game except ghouls and
goblins where you die in two hits I mean
the whole kind of a videogame system is
that when the easiest most forgiving
game is ghouls and goblins and I just
like to remind everyone that you spent
actual physical money on this like not
linden dollars or World of Warcraft gold
real money actual cash and then you know
that the yen was rising against the
dollar at the time I'm broke holy crap
what is this
I think the feds are at the door oh man
we are in beep sheepdip right now
we are violating all kinds of copyright
and or facing severe penalties so the
appellant yeah severe penalty like make
you play that motto King groans or game
or something all right
1941 counter-attack this is the most
expensive Super graphics game it cost me
$100 which is actually a good deal wait
a minute 1941 came out on like every
other video game system back then was
this like the ultimate super best
version or something damn well better be
man I am a weapon of mass destruction
with planes that could do this I don't
know how to war in the Pacific lasted so
long wait do you do you actually have a
life bar I do I can take hits and not
die instantly which is good because
they're more sprites here and a
coca-cola bottling plant responsible for
of the super graphics library
actually throws a lot of support behind
a lot of failed systems you know Saturn
gamecube fifi this is actually the best
game on the super graphics which is
really sad because you can get it on
Capcom Classics Collection for ps2 for
like $20 instead of the $100 you blew on
it which is $100 that you didn't spend
on like
half a dozen green casts in a glazed CD
I should not be given money Koller what
gives I'm not great at math but you said
there were like only five super graphics
games what's this oh well this is a PC
engine game that features upgraded
graphics when you play it on the super
graphics Darius plus yeah actually I
learned from the box that it pronounced
urias not Darius I don't know a multiple
scrolling backgrounds man just think if
you played it on turbo graphics it
wouldn't look this good and not even
look oh man this heart hurts my eyes
that's the worst explosion ever it's
smaller than the ship what is it with
home games have you put initials in for
a high score it's your game it's in your
house
Oh put an ass there we go stick it to
the man hi but I am the man it's my game
a man I'd ask you to tell me what kind
of obsessive nerd would actually buy the
super graphics and all the games but you
did it you can't psychoanalyze yourself
you're your archive is now complete
you've you've won the game of life
congratulations
why do I feel so empty